so this one was asked by AG bola who
wrote in the state the services i render
our accounting auditing taxation
management consultancy my question is
how can I market these services
professionally well so I mean you deal
with accountants all the time you see
tons of different entrepreneurs how can
how can they market them getting a good
question so first thing simple things if
you want to connect with us you've got
my email address with us i'll let you up
to something called the accountants sage
accountants network we've got a hundred
thousand accountants as part of that
part of what we do is product services
any entrepreneur who wants to have a
local accountant comes to the stage
accountants network all kind of
obviously Google Maps enabled and you
can find an accountant with the skills
and relevancy whether you're in
construction or whatever the hospitality
or whatever industry that I think the
other thing is this is selling vodka see
the the what you have is the brand is
trust and competence and I think with
with all these things it's always going
to be a referral business so you get in
first two clients and then it does go it
goes it goes completely seismic in terms
of how you conserve more clients and I
think the challenge you have is once
you're successful is how you keep the
quality of service and maintain that
quality of service you know it's easy to
do for your first 20 clients but when
you get up to 2 300 400 clients then how
do you actually maintain an Excel
exceptional now on this there's some
really good ways both ask that other
companies are doing some awesome work of
what we call real time accounted
integrated payments from your website
your shop window on the world right for
who invented management all these sort
of things so the manual handoffs and
where you need a lot of sort of people
that's bookkeepers and stuff is is
changing and the roles that you could
play is almost you can serve a lot of
stuff is what we call frictionless so it
kind of goes straight for it's a rule I
made it you run your business for the
pamir and on a smartphone and the role
of the accountants like yourself can be
tremendous
turns almost virtual finance director
CFO's of all your plants and you can say
you know your cash flow forecasts how do
you raise finance how do you go overseas
how do you get contracts that work out
in Europe and places like that so you
can play a much bigger role I think and
actually drive up your revenues and you
will value to your clients because
you're offering much hon tony servicing
kind of point number one there's a lot
of channels that can help you sages one
of them point number two is your
business is all about opposite build in
the first network of clients and they'll
recommend us all what entrepreneurs do
what they go down the Chamber of
Commerce where they go to the gym
wherever they go they'll recommend you
other people and then I think you could
build up a huge social presence around
that the other thing I'd love you to do
if you want to is build really good
content so when it comes up to the tax
year easy stuff how to help your clients
move much more quickly a lot of its
automated and you could build a really
good kind of website shot presence where
they not only can get hold of really
useful information but some tools to
actually help me more efficient in their
business so I think a lot of stuff going
on and a lot of disruption in technology
that you can take advantage for me I
would come back to we're talking about
visionary marketing what's your vision I
mean you tell me what you do but what's
the vision like how are you different
what are you staying for as an
accountant because if I need would you
accounting auditing taxation asa
consultancy there's a thousand you know
more like hundreds of thousands of
people I could go to for this service
why am I going to pick you out bola
what's so special about you what's the
better world that you want to create how
do you send out versus everybody oh
that's what I would lead with and then
when you're creating content when you're
talking to people that's what flows
through as an example there was a lawyer
friend of mine here in Toronto who was
trying to send out when you start as
legal practice and he this guy loves
entrepreneurs like really like has a
soft spot in his heart entrepreneurs
somebody that obviously I would be able
to connect with easily and he changed
his branding to be the entrepreneur
friendly lawyer a lot of lawyers aren't
seen as being friends of entrepreneurs
we don't like going to lawyers it's not
like it's a worst-case scenario kind of
thing
um and so that just that once wicked
being entrepreneur friendly made a huge
difference in him he will get his
message out and people didn't relate to
him in him standing out from a sea of
lawyers because it's tons of them so the
same thing for you you know all of the
all of the practical stuff we've been
talking about the content the
application amazing but what do you say
for like right now we could be helping
you with some high level stuff about
your vision and how to have a major
impact in the world but I don't know
enough about you how you introduce
yourself matters right so it's great I
want to know what you do but more
importantly I want to connect with who
you are as a person what you staying for
is an individual and the better world
that you're trying to create make me
feel something I'm getting excited I
ready for you because I feel it's in
there put that out in every
communication and that's going to like
people talk about you connect with you
wanna buy your services why I refer you
on that as well it's amazing if I go on
to your accountants kind of websites
once thing I think they could a lot of
people do is talk to their customers so
their clients so you know why don't we
have kind of using it so that your
trance out how you change their business
how you have you created millionaires
how you allow people to live their
dreams and allow them to focus on their
business and you talk terrible the back
office and just made that absolutely see
how you help them explore how you helped
them set up you know maybe set up
finance and allow them to accelerate
their growth and it would be great to
assume you know you just take your
iPhone along everybody wants to do it
because you're giving them free kind of
marketed you talk about marketing if I'm
a client of yours and I'm growing my
business at three hundred percent a year
I love it if I be on your website
there's a 30 second download video of me
talking about how fantastic services are
on how it'll help you explore to Canada
back to the UK over to you know fazil
and to stuff like that and then so the
story again connecting the emotion and
connecting and making it just it's all
about people it's all about connecting
the heart and I think come to Evans what
just a simple thing today will be go and
go and do kind of videos of you
customers at the end of the tax year and
how you assure them they sleep well
you